hi look at you
she's actually that kind of a hot bod
under all that tight-ass house from
[ __ ] I'm David oh wait um any how
you mean I'm Lenny where is it
King [ __ ] or is it my favorite
[Music]
[Applause]
what was a thing you're saying you were
talking about how the death of your
father affected you and I think that's
very brave okay the power of this thing
you're saying it has power nine days ago
David is a very powerful music he has to
be otherwise distinguish splitting apart
you know they are calling this thing it
what else could it be is not another
mutant and older isn't it
consciousness separated from its body
and living inside danger or 30 years
from now everybody has mentioned a
Deadpool Oh
Professor X in Deadpool it's not for me
to say well what about professor acting
Legion exactly so technically Patrick
Sir Patrick yes my father I mean yeah
did you know that David Hall is father
in the Marvel Universe is huge so
essentially I've got a job offer
this is massive are you in so tight are
you an milks Li 100% well this
hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my legion explainer season 2 but
you heard what you thought you just
heard Professor X and Deadpool's all
address that to the Logan giveaway still
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so careful for spoilers from
Allegiant if you don't care about
spoilers I'm going to explain who the
villain is 99% positive who he is from
the comics he's big comic book deep cut
the really cool thing about this I know
I put that Patrick Stewart clip there
he's basically talking about coming on
Legion season 2 as David's father
because he's his father in the comics
but the origins of the villain that I
think this person is is very tied up in
the origins of the x-men themself so it
all comes back around but to explain
that Aubrey Plaza secretly being the
villain of the season which i think is a
great reveal but if it wasn't clear from
those clips I cut together she is this
person just hiding in a different form
I'm Lenny no wait I'm Benny no wait I'm
King the dog the dog that David had as a
child that his sister later said we
never had a dog
so the problem at the beginning of the
season we've been seeing this read we
just knew something really ominous was
happening but now we know the red
represents him he is a separate entity
from David the key scene explaining that
where we find out that he's a parasite
was actually in episode 4 with Jermaine
Clemens character which was awesome he
was a hilarious character don't worry he
can't get you in him he monster ah he
makes you forget and he I wouldn't go
around there
it's waiting the monster
brought it in man and now continue there
is no monster to me I know that just
means my psychology hmm monster is
metaphor I like it but wrong part of you
that's true
but not like a symptom my largest
parasite hopefully we'll get to visit
him again in the astral plane during
season two but he says you brought your
friend in here with you he's been
following you around
he basically explains that he is
something else from the astral plane
which is weird okay so here's the big
reveal
the shadow king is from the comics so
right now all the evidence is pointing
at that at the beginning of the season
it wasn't quite so clear everyone was
like is this just a manifestation of one
of his personalities because in the
comics Legion has a thousand different
personalities they can manifest in the
physical world that's what's going on
with Carrie and Carrie she's an aspect
of him that manifests in the physical
world so in the last episode the shadow
king takes over David's mind uses his
body and his powers to go apeshit on
everybody and then we see him manifest
in the physical world that was what the
effect of him stepping through the
mirror as Aubrey Plaza was so the whole
idea is that he's been trapped in
David's consciousness without a physical
form he's been trying to find a way back
into the physical world and now it seems
like he has although he's in control of
David which is also the next best thing
the most powerful mutant on the planet
as far as we know with limitless
abilities the ones that we see on the TV
show are not the only abilities that he
has so he doesn't really need his own
physical form and he has powers that go
beyond what David has so as sort of this
dark God avatar married with this super
powerful mutant capable of containing
his essence so literally in this moment
it's the worst possible scenario
David's able to take them to his safe
place but it looks like they're still
not safe and then when they jump to that
circle of people talking it's almost
like they're saying The Shadow King has
taken over all of their minds and
they're now in a much different place it
just implies that they're all now in the
thrall of the
Shadow King so it's like oh my god the
big villains won but it's only Episode
five of eight so the idea is that at
some point David will rally or go
totally evil and either kick him out of
his mind
or he'll take over completely the really
important thing to remember is that when
the series was getting started they said
it was the deconstruction of a villain
origin story because Legion is mostly
known as a villain in the comics so the
whole idea here is that David is not a
villain yet but to tie it back to
Professor X so the whole thing is is
that in the comics the shadow king
starts out as this Amahl Farouk
character in the 1930s he runs into
Professor X they fight each other
he becomes the inspiration for Professor
X to create the x-men so Patrick
Stewart's saying that oh you know a
hundred percent I would be happy to come
on Legion allows them to do David's real
father because they just queued that up
on the show with this scene right here
where they say he was adopted no - why I
just need to know know so the big idea
of season one is that David's going to
have to defeat him inside his mind and
then we get to season two potential
Professor X revealed David this is your
real father and it can get even trickier
with x-men cannon but the other big bond
that Patrick Stewart dropped showing up
in Deadpool so regardless of what
happened during Logan no spoilers for
that movie if you haven't seen it yet it
said in the year 2029 Deadpool is kind
of ambiguous about what the timeline is
but think of it as like late 90s to
modern day some more contemporary either
way it'd be a much younger version of
Professor X he dropped a whole bunch of
f-bombs during Logan they had that
really funny joke about McAvoy or
Stewart during Deadpool Deadpool not
wanting to be an x-men they could
totally follow up on that it was one of
the best jokes from early in the film
listen the day I decided to become a
crime-fighting [ __ ] twizzler who rooms
with a bunch of other little whiners at
the neverland mansion of some creepy old
bald heaven's gate looking [ __ ]
on that day I'll send your shiny happy
ass a friend request
let's go talk to the professor McAvoy or
Stewart see silence no confusing the
funny thing about that is the Deadpool
is a key part of the x-force movie his
big thing is like he doesn't want to
join a team the x-men are so stupid
so they'll probably leave that in with
him forming x-force which is an r-rated
version of the x-men so that'll be a
really good opportunity for these
characters to make fun of him again
because all these Deadpool characters
has been confirmed for the sequel
they'll probably show up during x-force
too but I wouldn't expect Professor X
himself to have a really huge part to
something really impactful something
funny in the tone of Deadpool and
meaningful without completely taking you
out of the movie they're still casting
cable right now so that's still a ways
off but you can let me know how do you
want them to use Patrick Stewart in the
Deadpool movie but what's going to
happen next is I'll post my new arrow
video that might not be till Thursday
morning I have a new Avengers infinity
war video that I'll post after that so
whole bunch of comic book stuff coming
in the next couple of days what you wait
for that click here to learn all about
guardians of the galaxy to close credits
and click here to learn all about Domino
and Deadpool 2 thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video
you